what's going on everybody welcome to yet
another Q&A and this Q&A I want to be
answered kind of a handful of relatively
unrelated questions but first I got the
hoodies in from the IndieGoGo campaign
and here is nice
much better so the first question I got
here is which mobile operating system to
use Android or iOS and why I love how
you just assume I don't use Blackberry
or Windows but you're correct
um I use Android but it really has very
little to do with the operating system
itself and really more to do with the
actual phones that run those operating
systems so to me I think the best word
to use is that Android is just more fair
so for just some examples if I need to
replace the battery ok on my Android
devices all I do is pop off the back I
pop out the battery I put a new one no
problem
I need more storage I just get a micro
SD card pop it in these things are not
possible on the iOS like Apple phones
and that just drives me nuts I also when
I buy the phone I think paying like an
extra $100 or $200 or something for like
32 gigabytes more of storage is just
it's just outrageous it's unfair in my
opinion so that's why I don't use iOS
phones but my wife has always used Apple
phones and I mean they're great products
I don't mind the operating system the
only thing the other thing I kind of
noticed is Android phones at least the
ones that I've owned
typically seem to last longer than Apple
phones but again that's totally
anecdotal so who knows like I said I
mostly just use Android because I think
it's a more fair phone that's all the
next question if someone has an idea for
an app but doesn't know how to code buts
willing to learn how to code to make it
happen would it be better for this
person to learn to code or like hire
someone or like a coding company to do
it for them even if they're worried that
the idea could be stolen well there's
really kind of two parts here one is
like an idea being stolen so for the
most part ideas are pretty worthless
it's all about execution when it comes
to an app or something like this the app
itself generally is the exit
so I mean it is a realistic threat but
also it's really it's a lot deeper than
that so you'll you'll never be able to
like make a website or a web app and
just be like once and done so you can't
just like pay someone ten thousand
dollars for a website and then in think
that's the end of it there's always
gonna be development that's required so
I'm not really sure I would ever suggest
to somebody to hire like an outside
company you'd either want to hire
someone to work for you or with you or
or do it yourself I'm more of a
do-it-yourselfer so if it was me I would
just learn how to do it but there's some
things I don't learn how to do because I
don't want to or I don't enjoy it so for
example plumbing or something like that
in the house I'm gonna just hire someone
to do that because I don't get any
enjoyment out of that and then the same
thing is like I do most of the work on
my car so if I need to change the brakes
or the oil or something like that I'll
do it but if I need to rebuild an engine
or something I'm gonna get a
professional to do that so it really
just kind of depends but in your case a
price they either do it yourself or find
someone who shares your vision and
become partners
I would rarely suggest to get a coding
company to make you an app because
you're basically setting yourself up in
my opinion for trouble down the line
either you're gonna fail and it won't
matter or if you're successful you're
gonna now be dependent on that company
or have to find someone who's gonna work
on that like it's not totally legacy
code but someone else's code anyway
we're gonna next question from dro loud
with the avatar to match hey centex I'm
interests and IT security and pen
testing which language should I look
into currently learning Python at the
moment first of all I'm not really in
pen tester or IT security guys so I'm
probably not the greatest person to ask
but Python is a good language but in
terms of what languages you should learn
like all of them really because you're
going to be having to deal with any like
pen testing it just depends on what what
kind of systems are you pen testing and
what's on those systems so really a lot
more than probably just Python but
Python is a great scripting language
that is I know happens to be used in pen
testing a library you might be
interested in is pone tools pwnt OLS
it's a Python library so if you're
interested in learning pen testing with
Python you might want to look at that
exploit library anyway that's all I'm
gonna say on that
moving along got a comment here it's
kind of long so I'm gonna paraphrase but
basically it's just hey yeah I would
like to have basically a tutorial or
stream covering basically from beginning
to end of a kaggle challenge like here's
reference the Titanic data set yeah it's
totally possible I'm not sure I would
stream it necessarily to go all the way
through but I might stream something
like that my goal with the streams is
actually to keep them relatively short
and I might even just do streams as my
main way to record content from now on
and just stream the recording of that
content except for like some things
which just feedback from people is
absolutely pointless but then when I do
fill in the streams if you happen to be
there for the stream then you get to
kind of participate in the filming so
everything's still kind of up in the air
with the stream so I'm not really sure
how I'm gonna do it just yet but that's
kind of where I'm leaning at the moment
but anyway running through a full kaggle
competition for example or at least
challenge or whatever is totally
possible the second part of this
question is about the Udacity
self-driving car nanodegree and that
first challenge so actually I was going
to work with Udacity on that
self-driving car nano degree and got all
the way through to the very end and then
when it came time to sign contracts it
just felt kind of fat fell apart at the
end based on just money that's a paid
course it's an expensive paid course and
I felt like the payment for a person who
was gonna be contractor consulting on
that my job was going to be to create
projects basically and deal with that
code and I felt like for someone doing
self-driving car programming that that
rate was too low unacceptable I'm sure
some people someone took it and it's a
great resume builder I'm sure if like if
you want a resume builder I just I
didn't I thought working on the course
would be cool but anyway that's not your
question anyways I actually did that
first challenge as a sort of like prove
your worth thing and I did finish the
challenge I bet I know exactly what
you're stuck on it's at least for me
what I was like when I hit kind of a
block initially was draw straight lines
so
that one took me it took me probably
like an hour or something to figure that
one out because I didn't know how to
draw the straight line over the lane but
I did figure it out my way it's kind of
hacky but it actually it still works
with the frames per second and stuff and
it's not absolutely horrendous so anyway
yeah maybe I could cover that I'm not
sure I could use their exact video but
there's tons of open-source videos that
I could use that form so the next
question here is how do you decide what
topic your videos are going to be on so
the way that I usually do this is it's
just something that I'm personally
interested in so either I just got done
working on something and I want to share
it with everybody or I'm interested in
learning something so I'll learn it and
teach it purely just to learn it so it's
either usually one of those two things I
also take requests or suggestions on
certain modules or topics or whatever to
cover and I do that not necessarily
because I like tally it up and then go
with what the majority wants I generally
do that just to become aware of new
things that I haven't even heard of at
the time so yeah so that's pretty much
how I how I decide on what kind of
content to cover so the final question
I'm gonna answer here is your Twitter
profile tells you are an introvert how
did you prepare yourself to appear in
video tutorials or public facing is
something you're comfortable with
basically how do i reconcile having such
a public facing job I suppose with being
an introvert so for those of you not
familiar with my Twitter I just have on
there it's like INTJ that's my my breyer
Miggs classification I can't think of
the proper term anyway yeah so INTJ and
part of the eye there is introverted and
I think that probably the biggest thing
here is there's maybe a slight
misconception on what introvert actually
means
introvert doesn't necessarily mean
antisocial but at the same time I
wouldn't can I wouldn't confuse running
a YouTube channel as being a social
activity certainly not in the sense of
that you might initially think cuz I
mean the reality of situation is I'm
sitting in my room and I'm talking to a
webcam yeah it's gonna reach like
thousands of people but at the same time
it's a very a very personal thing for me
like I'm
not actually having to engage with 5,000
people I mean if that's what will happen
but at the same time it's a very
different but also even even then a lot
of like public speakers and like leaders
like company CEOs stuff like that are
actually introverts and will identify as
introverts and in the differences
I guess the relationship with your
audience or coworkers or whatever it
might be so for example like a good
example is indeed like a public speaker
who's okay with like speaking to say a
huge audience of hundreds of people and
that's okay but then getting offstage
and then having to interact with those
hundreds of people at the same time
that's very demanding for an introvert
okay so another good way to think of it
as like an introvert is someone who is
drained by social interaction and an
extrovert someone who actually like gets
energy from the social interactions so
for like me personally I'd much more
rather converse and hang out with a
small group of people like two or three
people whereas I like my wife likes to
have like 20 people over or something
like that and whenever I get in big
groups of people I tend to just like sit
back and just like listen to what
everyone's saying like I very rarely
take part in a conversation that large
it's just not enjoyable to me as much I
don't mind sitting back and listening
but it's definitely like that I think
that's just like a trait of being
introverted also I'm not a psychologist
I get that number or that you know INTJ
classification just from taking like a
test that basically tells you you can
find them online and stuff they're like
they're pretty long it's like a hundred
something question testers but it's kind
of cool anyway hopefully that answers
your question basically I just I don't
really consider a youtube channel as
something that extroverts tend to do I
think this is a great example like where
I feel like in this setting yeah I reach
a large group of people but it's yet a
fairly personal setting at least for me
I'm filming in my own house and all that
kind of stuff anyway
that's it for the Q&A the next Q&A is
going to be on artificial intelligence
I've been asked artificial intelligence
questions since the very first Q&A and
I've been kind of putting it off because
it's going to take
basically an entire QA to really answer
that question and really won't even
really truly answer the question but
there are a few things that I think are
relatively unique on my thoughts on what
the real true threat of AI is and it's
not what most people seem to think it is
so I'd be happy to share that with you
if you have any a eye specific questions
now would be the time to ask otherwise
you can ask other questions too and I'll
get to them not in the next one but the
one right after that so thus National
should be on I think the 31st so I do
think that there are questions of AI
that will be of utmost importance
especially for the year 2017 just
watching kind of what has happened in
2016 and what we're what we're headed
towards so anyway some pretty serious
issues in my opinion but anyway that's
what we'll be talking about in the next
video questions comments below I'll see
you in another video